il y a différentes manières de faire des films
qui ont des personnages CG ce qui nous
intéresse avec la capture de performance
est la totalité de la performance
physique émotionnel facial les yeux
tout ce que l'acteur crée l'émotion que
l'acteur crée le moment c'est notre
travail de s'assurer que tout  l'
acteur a fait est préservé dans leur
personnage CG vous êtes très dur avec
le père c'est mon travail tout ce que
Jake Sully en tant que navi fait Sam a fait
[Musique]
vous pouvez capturer l'émotion vous pouvez
capturer les subtilités les nuances
des mouvements vous pouvez  capturer l'œil
et capturer les tiques tout
capturer tout je serai gentil une fois
puis je ne le serai pas
au moment où je l'ai vue pour la première fois
j'étais comme tu es tellement belle le
bleu n'a jamais été aussi beau
juste une famille
la chose étonnante est que la technologie
me donne ce portail pour amener mon moi de 14
ans à jouer cette fille les avatars ne
font que tourner
en faisant un film sur Pandora
Pandora n'existe pas d'avatars don
n'existe pas à neuf pieds de haut, nous avons des acteurs
travaillant dans un volume avec des marqueurs sur
leur corps des plates-formes de tête faciale sur leur
tête et nous capturons cent pour cent de
leur performance dans le monde numérique
au début de la journée, la première
chose que nous faisons est  entrez dans le
FC de capture de performances et c'est un
deux pièces moulant et il est totalement rempli de
piscines de type ping-pong autour de nous afin qu'ils
puissent ensuite suivre mon bras et ensuite traduire
cela dans le monde virtuel, ils ont
toutes ces petites caméras qui envoient  ces
petits rayons qui donnent une image de vous en
mouvement, donc chaque petit mouvement
est votre mouvement, puis nous mettons une
plate-forme de tête et c'est un casque et il a une
caméra qui est juste devant votre
visage l'une des grandes avancées que nous '  que j'ai
fait technologiquement sur les suites est
la capture de la performance faciale que nous
capturons une fidélité de performance beaucoup plus élevée
mais je sais une chose
[Musique]
cette famille est notre forteresse
J'ai fait beaucoup d'écran vert que j'ai
fait  un  beaucoup d'écran bleu mais jamais
rien de tel bien sûr où il n'y a
vraiment pas d'écran vous agissez juste
dans un espace non vous devez supporter la
sauce
j'ai toujours pensé qu'être dans le
volume c'est jouer et Imagination
et il n'y a pas de genre  de peur ou pas de honte,
vous pouvez faire tout ce que vous devez faire pour
arriver à cette vérité en sauvant leur vie,
c'est tout ce qui compte J'ai dû
travailler complètement différemment de ce que j'ai jamais
fait auparavant et ce fut une
expérience incroyable de remonter dans le temps
Je suis différent
[Music]
c'est juste remarquable de pouvoir voir
les mouvements et la performance entrer
directement dans le personnage et c'est
comme s'il y avait la Renault de Kate et Heather,
donc ça m'a fasciné
qu'est-ce que c'est fait
oh qu'est-ce que c'est que
je trouve  en tant que réalisateur, je suis beaucoup plus à l'
écoute des acteurs parce que c'est tout ce dont
je dois m'inquiéter je ne suis pas distrait
par le mouvement de caméra ou les figurants en
arrière-plan je suis juste là pour eux
c'est tout ce qui m'importe c'est tout  je
suis  c'est un processus incroyable c'est
aussi la seule façon de le faire c'est la seule
façon de faire ce film
[Musique]